the Trump administration lays out a
highly restrictive set of guidelines for
daily life the stock market collapses in
San Francisco shuts everything down I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
Express at VPN you have a right to
privacy protected and expressvpn dot-com
/ Ben okay so here is the dealio the
dealio gang right now we are trying to
figure out exactly what the plan is
I mean seriously entire US government is
trying to figure out the plan is the
entire world is trying to figure out
what the plan is this is because we can
quarantine all we want but once the
quarantine ends once people are out and
about then is this thing just going to
crop up again and we don't know the
answer to that question so right now
everything is shut down this shutdown is
basically because we're trying to as
we've explained on the show before
flatten the curve the goal being that
yeah everybody eventually is gonna get
coronavirus it'll become part of our
sort of seasonal flu daily life this
sort of the theory but if we can flatten
that curve so that it doesn't all hit at
once oh the wrecking ball doesn't hit
our healthcare system all at once then
you won't have a massive excess of cases
above that dotted line that I've shown
you before the dotted line being the
number of ICU beds and respirators and
ventilators available for people who
actually need them so the idea is we can
slow transmission to a certain extent
then eventually there will be enough
beds available because people won't all
be getting this at once
but here is the problem let's say that
we lock everything down for just a
couple of weeks let's say we lock
everything down for a couple of months
and then all the young people go out and
they hang out together and then they
infect one another and then all the old
people get it well you may have delayed
it a little bit but unless you have
radically increased the number of ICU
beds and ventilators then you've not
actually bought anything you've not
actually achieved anything because the
line is still where it was before all
you've done is basically delay a little
bit the onset of the tsunami that is
going to hit so the question right now
is what is going to stop this thing now
the evidence is sort of interesting and
mixed on what is going to stop this
thing so in China if we believe the
Chinese statistics the Chinese have
actually stopped this thing dead they
locked everybody down for about three
months and now they're very new few new
cases according to the Chinese
government we have seen industry start
to reopen we're seeing people on the
streets again in Hong Kong same thing
lots of people out in the streets again
clear weather business is reopened at
this point in South Korea or not so the
question is going to be now that people
are back out and about whether they are
starting to reinfect each other and
whether you see the caseloads rising
again if not then there is a hope that
this thing is just shut down temporarily
and if it's shut down temporarily then
we can weather this thing if however
there is no shutdown that is temporary
if however it turns out that the minute
we get out of our hidey holes and we
start associating with one another we're
gonna reinfect each other again and then
it's going to hit all the old people
anyway and we have not significantly
increased the number of beds we haven't
bought ourselves any time at all and if
the vaccine takes 12 to 18 months and
the idea is that we're supposed to shut
down the entire world economy for 12 to
18 months that is simply unsustainable
which is why it's fascinating to see the
differences between how the United
States and the UK and Denmark are
treating this things I mentioned this
yesterday the United States is right now
basically pursuing a policy of everybody
stay home which is based on best
available information everybody's
staying home is going to slow the
transmission of the disease okay the UK
was pursuing a policy originally of herd
immunity let everybody who's under the
age of 60 walk around freely go about
their business get the corona virus
develop an immunity to corona virus and
then once it's passed through the
population there's not as much chance
that all of those people are going to
pass it on to the old people the problem
is it turns out that a lot of the people
were still visiting with old people
grandma and grandpa we're still getting
it and this is why the UK is now
imposing american-style restrictions
meanwhile in Denmark they're trying the
UK style experiment they're basically
saying everybody under the age of 70 go
about your daily business go enjoy your
life it'll develop herd immunity if
you're over the age of 70 stay in your
house we're gonna slip a rent check and
some food under your door and just deal
with it for like three to four months
it'll be interesting to see which one of
these bears the most dividends in the
long term it may actually be the Danish
example it may be Denmark the reason
being again if the if the goal here is
not just to lower the curve but to
eradicate the passage of the disease
generally you do need to hurt immunity
at a certain point the benefits of a
slow development of the disease over
time toward herd immunity is that you
don't fill all the ICU beds at once the
downside is it means that you have to
shut down the economy for
extraordinarily broad periods of time in
in Denmark the hope is that if you can
segment off people who are older that
you can get the best of both worlds that
all those old people will not get the
disease and all the young people
we'll get it but most of them will be
okay my most we mean nearly all of those
people will basically be okay these are
the sort of trade-offs that public
policy has to take into consideration
because the economy shutting down is a
major public policy consideration
millions of jobs are gonna be lost
across the world of this month and next
in the United States hundreds of
thousands of jobs are gonna be lost this
month and next the reason being you
can't shut down the entire United States
economy indefinitely
without any without any sort of
expectation as to when the economy is
gonna open without inflating the
currency I mean at a certain point who's
gonna buy bonds at a certain point where
is the money all gonna be and once you
start inflating the currency so people
can continue to pay for their food well
what happens to everybody who has
savings all the people who are really
wealthy don't actually have a lot of
money anymore basically all the wealth
of a society dissipates when the economy
stops dead this way these are serious
considerations that we're gonna have to
consider and we're gonna have to hear
some more specific plans from our
leadership as to how they expect that
this thing is going to die out or how we
expect to increase the medical capacity
of the system itself so that when we
reopen the doors when business reopens
we don't have exactly the same situation
we had two weeks ago where business is
open but lots of old people are in
danger of dying we're gonna get to more
of this we're gonna break it down in
just one second because data first here
before opinion data first we'll get to
all of that in just one second first let
us talk about the fact that your car
right now kind of valuable to you and
one of the things you don't want to be
doing is heading out to that auto parts
store so you got a breakdown you're not
gonna go to the auto parts store because
a lot of these businesses are shut
anyway why not check out Rock Auto calm
it's so much easier than walking into a
store and then demanding quick answers
to things like Odyssey is your Odyssey
and LX or Annie X and what kind of part
do you need is it the specific exact
part many of your parts right now are
basically computer based and that means
that you don't have the exact part and a
local auto parts store besides which it
may be closed right now so go check out
Rock Auto calm the rockauto.com catalog
is unique remarkably easy to navigate
rockauto.com has everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil even new carpet whether
it's for your classic or daily driver
get everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do why spend up to
twice as much for the same parts
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
just twenty years I mean let me just
give you a quick example Adelphi FG
14:56 fuel pump assembly for 2005 to
2010 honda odyssey is 354 bucks at
advance which is a big chain store
versus 217 dollars at rockauto.com so
next time your car gives you trouble
instead of heading off to the auto parts
store which is probably closed
instead head on over to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck and right
Shapiro's in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you okay so as I say the big questions
right now involve exactly when we reopen
the economy if the economy is reopened
how exactly all of this shakes out so
here's the information that we currently
have right now according to the new york
times benedict carry writing science is
tracking the spread of coronavirus
reported on Monday that for every
confirmed case they are most likely
another five to ten people in the
community with undetected infections
these often milder cases are on average
about half as infectious as confirmed
ones but I responsible for nearly 80% of
new cases according to the report which
was based on data from China
the researchers modelled the viruses
natural spread in China before the
government instituted a travel ban an
aggressive aggressive testing policy
during that time from December of last
year through late January about six in
seven cases went undetected that
situation is analogous to the current
state of affairs in the United States
and other Western countries or tests are
not widely available the researchers
said Jeffrey Shaymin epidemiologist at
Columbia he says if we have three
hundred three thousand five hundred
confirmed cases in the United States you
might be looking at thirty five thousand
in reality the report is among the first
to address two of the most pressing
questions about the pandemic how many
people are walking around with
unrecognized infections and just how
infectious are they as American
policymakers have begun taking more
aggressive measures to slow
transmissions such as canceling events
and closing restaurants access to test
for the virus has been difficult or
non-existent in much of the country
those tests are going to be necessary in
order for us to actually lock down
people who may be walking around and
carrying this thing without noticing it
dr. Elizabeth Halloran professor of
biostatistics at the University of
Washington says it's crucial to
implement wide scale testing and it's
important to develop an expensive test
so people can get tested whenever they
need to be this new analysis is drawing
undocumented infections in China and
mobility data as well as a model of
social interaction across the population
to estimate the numbers of undocumented
cases as well as infection rates it
found that after the Chinese government
locked down the center of the outbreak
on January 23rd and
and widespread testing the picture
changed drastically in time testing
identified some 60% of positive cases up
from 14% the scientists said the number
of undetected cases for every confirmed
one could vary twofold from country to
country the unidentified cases in China
that proliferated before the lockdown
although less contagious did not
necessarily cause milder cases in the
newly infected according to researchers
okay so this does require us to ask the
question with regards to China so why
exactly have we not seen a reef to of
cases in China as the economy begins to
open because as the New York Times
reported earlier this week I mean
reported like late last week China is
starting to get back to work
more than 6 weeks after its leaders
virtually shut down the world's second
largest economy factories are reopening
offices are starting to fill okay if
that's the case then why haven't we seen
a wild uptick in the number of cases in
China almost they're not telling us
something about how all of this works
because for example The Washington Post
this is one of the most viewed pieces in
the history of the Washington Post in
for good reason it's a sophisticated and
interesting take on exactly how
infection models work so we're gonna
show you how the Washington posted this
because it's really interesting so
basically they created a fake disease
called Samia lightest okay trying to
simulate Kovan 19 this one passes more
easily than kovin 19 where a helper the
person comes into contact with the sick
person the healthy person becomes sick
in this particular model and then
they're recovered people so what you're
about to see if you can actually watch
the show is you're about to see dots of
three colors right you're gonna see
purple dots those are people have
recovered from simulators which in this
case is sort of a more viral version of
corona virus you're gonna see the the
sort of greenish gray dots those are
healthy people and then you're gonna see
the orange dots and those are sick
people and there are a bunch of
different simulations that they are that
they have put out there so simulation
number one this simulation is a
free-for-all basically everybody travels
as they see fit there are no travel
lockdowns
everybody is able to go and do exactly
what it is that they want we can play
that then I can explain what's happening
so you can see there's this one sick
person starts infecting people almost
immediately now all the people are
infecting all the other people and what
you see is very very quickly the
sickness spreads throughout the entire
population you can see on the top of the
graphic this is why should subscribe its
daily wires you can actually see what
we're talking about you can see at the
top of the graph
this big bell curve and the bell curve
quickly spikes all the way to the top of
the chart before finally starting to
drop off as people start recovering now
what these charts do not include is the
number of people who die so those people
are no longer infectious obviously but
it's a fairly good simulation of what
exactly this stuff looks like if there
are no restrictions in place at the time
so this was able to spread quickly over
an entire population in a bigger country
right there's a very small country right
you're only talking about a couple
hundred a couple hundred dots when you
see that what you're seeing is that the
entire population is infected in a very
short amount of time but then everybody
is recovered right so the question is if
you're looking for herd immunity maybe
you don't want to restrict everything
right the theory here would sort of be
the Danish theory which is okay fine so
everybody gets sick and then everybody
recovers so you want this to happen as
quickly as possible okay then you have
your second model of how to contain this
thing and this would be the attempted
quarantine okay so this is where you
literally just wall off a portion of the
population and what you see is that
within the portion of the population
that is walled off the infections happen
really really fast right so let's say
you wolof a nursing home and somebody in
the nursing home has the infection
everybody in the nursing home has the
infection within about five seconds
everybody outside the nursing home does
not have the infection now the problem
is as you will see in this particular
model is that as the door opens right as
you start to get beyond the attempted
quarantine then some of the sick people
are going to escape and then they're
going to start infecting the population
and then you get this sort of secondary
spike or all of a sudden a lot of people
are getting the infection but you've
seen that the curve has been flattened
so the idea here would be sort of what
the United States is trying everybody
stay home now that you're staying home
the the curve is rising but rising later
and so the idea is because the curve
here is flatter then presumably the the
number of beds that are built in the
mean time are going to relieve pressure
on the healthcare system now that only
works if you actually raise the number
of beds that are available it only works
if you actually pay for new ventilators
it only works just if you build new
hospitals so all of that has to happen
in this model in order for the effects
not to be as bad as the first model
where you just let everybody run around
without any sort of restrictions okay
then there's the third model the third
model is moderate social distancing in
moderate social distancing this happens
when about a quarter of the population
moves around
everybody else stays home or socially
distances all right so this is sort of
what the United States has kind of right
now right this is what we've been
pursuing which is basically a small
percentage of the population is moving
around some people are going to work
most people are now staying home in
major cities and here's what that looks
like over time so you see that people
are the one sick person will move around
every - every person they hit gets sick
but they're hitting a lot fewer people
because not that many people are moving
around and so the entire disease vector
just moves a lot more slowly like a lot
more slowly yeah people are getting the
symptoms but it's happening
extraordinarily slowly over time there
are a lot of healthy people a couple of
recovered people and and and very few
sick people or examine the curve here is
very flat so that's what the United
States is going for again in order to
keep that number below the dotted line
of the the number of ICU beds over time
now the problem with this is it doesn't
develop herd immunity so if at a certain
point people get back to work then you
immediately kick into chart number one
and then the number of cases spikes
again and this is the point I'm making
we don't know what's going to end this
disease vector right will this there's a
great hope that the summer ends the
disease vector that basically we get to
summer warmer weather flu tends to die
off in warmer weather and then everybody
gets back to work for a few months while
we build some new ICU beds by the time
we hit fall we don't have to shut down
the economy again in the same way but
that is assuming some things like that
this is gonna kill the virus which
there's some fairly good evidence for
that in equatorial zones it seems like
the virus is being killed off faster and
in hot areas hot and humid seems to be
killing off the virus so we can all pray
that that is the case so that would be
the idea behind a temporary mostly
lockdown which is kind of what we in the
United States are pursuing that's the
policy that we're looking at right now
then there's extensive social distancing
extensive social distancing would be
like San Francisco right now this is one
out of every eight people moving meaning
barely anyone is moving at all and you
can play that simulation as well again
all these simulations are courtesy of
The Washington Post which did an
excellent job putting together what
these graphics look like for those who
kick again can't see what you are seeing
here is a few sick people who are moving
around and everybody else locking in
place and again you're seeing the
caseload
grow extraordinarily slowly and again
that that is what you would really look
for right so both the moderate case and
the extensive social distancing you see
a bell curve that is much shallower
and also back-loaded right there that
bell
is back loaded because again whatever
whatever increase is taking place is
taking place a lot later over time its
cumulative over time so that is what the
United States is looking for is to lay
this thing until summer and then hope
pray that the hot weather kills the flu
I mean killing the Wu hen flu and by the
way it's not races to call it will hen
flu we'll get to that in a second it
originated in Wuhan the Spanish flu is
the Spanish flu this is the Wuhan flu
okay so this is the model that the
United States is pursuing okay so bottom
line if you look at what these look like
okay in terms of the bell curve if you
have the free-for-all which is sort of
what Denmark is positing you have that
steep bell curve steep up steep down and
then you're done
the attempted quarantine you have a much
shallower curve and then you have a
secondary curve that is much broader
okay the second that the goal there
would be to shut this thing down at
least for the moment so you can get that
ICU level just above this sort of orange
double bell curve or just above the
camel humps right there and then you
have moderate distancing which is what
the United States is trying in the short
term and depends how long we can keep
that thing lasting and then the hope is
that when you hit the end of that chart
by that point we have a vaccine by that
point we have the summer and this thing
gets killed off in an extensive
distancing is just a better variation
moderate distancing so the United States
is basically trying strategies three and
four moderate distancing an extensive
distancing Denmark is trying strategy
one and the idea would be that you wall
off all of the oldies and you make sure
that they don't actually get hurt all of
this is reliance again on a couple of
assumptions assumption number one summer
comes the flu dies assumption number two
a vaccine is developed sometime in the
near future if neither one of those
things happens nothing we are doing
right now is gonna matter seriously if
not if we do not develop either more ICU
beds right better medical capacity to
handle people who are getting sick over
the course of the next couple of months
or if this does not kill off if the
summer does not kill off the Wu hen flu
or if we get to the point where a
vaccine is developed if none of those
three things happen then no matter how
much social distancing we go through
right now if this thing lives
everybody's gonna get infected old
people are going to die in increased
numbers okay so we are relying on a few
things that are unknown we just don't
have the information for it it's kind of
best bet kind of stuff and again as a
social matter is gonna be a social
science matter will be fascinating to
see whether Denmark has the best
approach keeping their economy running
well maybe everybody else is
overreacting or whether we have the
right approach and Denmark would on four
we see some pretty bad effect from what
they're doing also what happens when we
reopen our borders right the world we
are not walled off from the world now
we're just gonna keep travel bans from
every place on earth in place
interminably or is the idea that we are
going to gradually relax those travel
bans again policy is completely in flux
right now well get some more of this in
just one Technol bring you the latest
news and then the Trump response they've
issued some new CDC guidelines we'll get
to that in a second first you know right
now you might be thinking a lot about
death well this would also be a good
time you're sitting at home you don't
have a lot to do maybe what you should
do is go check out policy genius and get
yourself some life insurance like now
would be a great time to get yourself
some life insurance policy genius makes
finding the right life insurance a
breeze in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers and find your best
price it could save fifteen hundred
dollars or more a year by using policy
changes to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home auto and disability
insurance so if you don't know what's
just around the corner
nobody does okay this is why you need
insurance go make sure that you your
family are taken care of in case god
forbid something should happen to you it
wasn't bad enough if somebody dies but
it's you know that much worse if their
stream of revenue and stream of income
is completely cut off to their family
and it's just the responsible thing to
do if you got a family
go get life insurance right now shop
competitively and get the best possible
deal the best possible price from policy
genius.com policy genius everybody gets
the future wrong who could have
predicted this crap but it's better to
get life insurance right policy
genius.com go check it out right now
okay so all of this has some pretty
significant financial implications we've
gone through all the simulations showing
you how exactly all these various
policies would work no quarantine
partial quarantine total quarantine
every staying home right we've gone
through all of that the financial
ramifications of each of these makes a
huge difference because the fact is that
if we have no data and when the economy
gets restarted if the idea is we're just
gonna stay in lockdown until there's a
vaccine which could take 12 to 18 months
the world economy is not that's not a
recession that's a depression because
the fact is their business is operating
on the margins right now that are going
to go under which is awful in and of
itself
a lot of people gonna lose their
livelihoods over the next couple of
months and the government is stepping in
and taking measures along these lines
right the Fed says that it's gonna offer
an additional five hundred billion
dollars in overnight repo funding
markets to prevent people prevent
creditors from
going in and trying to repossess stuff
right from from calling in their loans
they're basically saying guys hold off
everything's on hold the federal
government is gonna pump into you to
make sure that you don't experience his
losses necessary for you to call in all
of those mortgages call in all those car
loans calling all the student loans
we're gonna step in right now and we're
gonna stop gap this thing for the moment
and that's good policy so long as it's a
stopgap it cannot be permanent because
eventually how you gonna fund this
they're only a couple of ways you can
fund this right one is that you are
betting that sometime in the future
taxpayer dollars will pay for this and
so you're selling off bonds and then who
do you sell the bonds to if the rest of
the economy is shut down who can afford
to buy the bonds right every single
country on planet earth right now is in
the same situation the United States is
in so real gonna sell our bonds to each
other
who exactly is the bond buyer at that
point right is is the Chinese government
going to buy American bonds I mean the
Chinese government is already
bankrupting itself so today of the money
to buy American bonds maybe they buy
American bonds in the hopes that
America's economy recovers faster but
again that is all dependent on the
underlying condition being alleviated if
coronavirus is not alleviated over the
next 12 to 18 months there will be no
bond market nobody is going to be buying
into the future Faith and Credit of a
country where the entire industry is
shut down and globally nobody can afford
to buy those bonds okay which leaves the
federal government with only a couple of
other options one of those is to
actually pump right to actually inflate
the currency to basically helicopter
cash everywhere just give everybody
doodles of money okay once that happens
sounds great only one problem once you
start helicopter cashing everything
eventually prices prices are going to
rise because again it doesn't lower the
cost of production of the goods that are
still in production to simply helicopter
cash everything and what that means is
that everybody who has savings is now
worth less because the stock market is
not gonna rise on that base I mean we
know this because this is actually what
FDR tried to do during the Great
Depression during the Great Depression
there was an attempt by FDR to basically
set wages set prices top-down government
control lengths in the Great Depression
by eight years hey if you do not
alleviate the underlying condition here
the Great Depression is even less
understandable because there was no
great underlying condition that led to
the Great Depression here you actually
have an underlying condition coronavirus
presumably when that is healed in some
way then you are going to see an uptick
in the economy but if there is no
prospect of an uptick then there will
come a point where everybody is just
going to have to
danish solution there will come a point
where the economy can no longer afford
to operate on the space and that's gonna
be dangerous and it's gonna be terrible
and we're gonna have to make some very
very difficult public policy decisions
as to which sectors are allowed to go
back to work what is the risk factor for
people who are older in our society
right we hope we never get to that the
great hope is that by summer by May this
thing starts to die down and again many
scientists are suggesting that that may
be exactly what happens that perhaps we
get to the point pretty quickly
you know hopefully as we say by May that
this thing starts to drop off a little
bit in terms of its virulence and that
the government has gotten it under
control but if it does not then all of
the measures the government is taking
right now in order contain this thing
are not going to have a lot of a long
term effect and the economy is gonna
stay down for the count
right that is the great fear so we can
all take these measures right every week
is it we can all stay home government
can pump we can do that for a market
period of time we cannot do that
interminably we cannot do it forever
they don't make cannot just print money
or borrow money on the basis of revenue
that's never going to arrive based on
lowered economic projections now again
most economists believe that we're gonna
come out of this fairly quickly meaning
that there will be a ruff-ruff queue to
the queue to in the Uniting Goldman
Sachs is projecting that queue to in the
United States we're gonna see a four
percent GDP loss which is just
astonishing
and that then afterward we'll see they
hope an alleviation and a 2% GDP gain
that will see a u-shaped recovery and by
the end of the year we'll have gone
through the year with a slight loss the
stock market today is sort of assuming
there's not going to be tremendous
amounts of new information available the
stock market is up slightly today at
this point it dropped 3,000 points
yesterday it is up and down and up and
down because nobody knows where the
actual bottom is nobody knows where
exactly this thing is going and with
that said everybody is shutting down and
there's not gonna be any new information
for a couple of weeks now here's the
thing you're gonna see a lot of
statistics in the next couple of weeks
about the number of cases rising that's
good that's a good thing that's what you
want
the reason you want that it's cuz the
case has already exist it's not that
seeing the number of cases that are in
the in the system means there are more
new cases it means we're now finally
testing which is something that is
deeply necessary at this point okay in
just a second we're gonna get to the
latest measures being taken by states
and localities we're gonna get to the
new White House guidelines we can get to
all of that and just once
first let's talk about one reality
you're amusing the male an awful lot in
the near future but do you really want
to schlep over the post office there are
lines there okay and forget about the
length of the lines social distancing
man that seemed like a good idea to
you'd it to go out to to the post office
and schlep a bunch of packages there
seems like a bad idea to me this is why
you should be using stamps calm beyond
all the other reasons like saving tons
of time and money
stamps.com is completely online plus if
you save five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off
shipping rates you are doing really well
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed at
that simple think about how much time
and money you could have saved on
letters and packages over the years and
think about the fact that they're
telling you to stay home you can stay
home and still use stamps calm stamps
calm is a no-brainer it saves you time
it saves you money it saves you the
hassle of having to be out in public at
a time when you're not some really
supposed to be out in public right now
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and the digital scale no long
term commitment just head on over to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in at
Shapiro data stamps calm enter code
Shapiro I'll go check it out right now
okay so the San Francisco Bay Area is
the first place in the nation that has
essentially told people to shelter in
place this is going to become very
quickly I think the standard for the
United States one of the things that
happens in these situations is you don't
want to be the public leader who gets
left behind you don't wanna be the
outlier right Denmark is taking enormous
amounts of flack for exactly the
policies I was talking about before the
UK was taking an enormous amount of
flack for the policies that I was
talking about before how would you like
to be the mayor who says everybody go
about your business and then you get an
outbreak in your city and by the way
that's a real possibility right I mean
during the Spanish flu there's a
widespread difference 1918 to 1920 huge
difference in death rates between
Philadelphia where everybody just went
about their business and st. Louis where
these shelter and place orders were
basically put in place and the death
rate was half of that in Philadelphia
well now six bay area counties have
announced shelter and place orders for
all residents on Monday directing
everyone to stay inside their homes and
away from others as much as possible for
three weeks in a desperate move to curb
the rapid spread of coronavirus across
the region the director was set to begin
at midnight on Tuesday and involves San
Francisco Santa Clara San Mateo Marin
Contra Costa and Alameda counties a
combined population of more than
point seven million people it's gonna
stay in place until at least April
seventh the three other Bay area
counties Sonoma Solano and Napa did not
issue similar mandates also Santa Cruz
County announced a shelter-in-place
order for its two hundred and
seventy-five thousand residents in all
likelihood this is going to become sort
of the common standard across America
we've already seen shutdowns basically
all businesses in the city of Los
Angeles restaurants our clothes except
for takeout movie theaters are closed
retail stores are closed we are seeing
that in DC we are seeing that in New
York I mean we've never seen anything
like this truly and then in the history
of the United States mean even during
World War Two the stores were open this
is this is astonishing stuff businesses
that do not provide essential services
must send workers home must according to
these orders among those remaining open
our grocery stores pharmacies
restaurants for delivery only and
hardware stores as well most workers are
ordered to stay home exceptions are just
health care workers police fire other
emergency responders and utility
providers such as electricians and
plumbers and sanitation workers Bart
will run for a central Travel airports
are not closing either although the fact
is that domestic airline travel is
basically dead at this point so the you
know that that is the airline industry
is in serious trouble they're just gonna
have to shut down they're just gonna
have to shut down meanwhile there's
controversy over in Ohio where Governor
Mike DeWine has postponed a primary
election and the idiotic Democratic
Party an idiot Tom Perez have said we're
gonna go ahead with our primary today
anyway well good luck with that
I mean seriously I mean the the governor
there's been talk about you know a judge
said you can't shut it down into wine
said I am shutting it down and people
are like well this is a constitutional
crisis no the negotiations between
executive branch's and the judiciary are
ongoing it is not a violation of
American governance for a governor to
say listen I'm not gonna pay attention
to that court order and then the thing
gets elevated again in emergency
situations this sort of stuff tends to
go by the wayside - wine tweeted during
this time when we face unprecedented
public health crisis to conduct an
election tomorrow would force poll
workers and voters to place themselves
in an unacceptable health risk of
contracting coronavirus meanwhile the
Secretary of State Frank LaRose said
that he's going to seek a remedy through
the courts to extend voting options so
every voter who wants to vote will be
granted that opportunity frankly I'm
shocked that he ends he decided to go
forward with this thing anyway okay
meanwhile the White House announced all
sorts of new guidelines yesterday sorry
first there are no shortages okay so the
side you don't have to rush over to the
grocery store of the pharmacy these
things will be stocked NBC's Nightly
News with a Lester Holt was pointing out
that the supply chains are still in
place the good news is nobody starving
thank God okay the fact is that
capitalism amazing solutions you
stocking the shelves here is here's
Lester Holt reporting last night on NBC
News so there will be food there's not a
reason to stock up just come back
tomorrow in Maryland today trucks loaded
with supplies headed to a slammed Costco
the same in Florida pinched public
stores getting resupply in California
the north gate Gonzales market one of
many shoppers now opening early just for
older shoppers 65 and up we're gonna
have exclusive for seniors and tonight
at an Aldi there is enough toilet paper
okay so that of course is good news the
White House yesterday came out announced
summit new guidelines President Trump
said that this outbreak could last until
July or August originally the media
reported that Trump is going to keep all
these restrictions in place until July
or August the fact is we do not know how
long these restrictions are going to
last in reality do you think the
American people are going to simply
shelter in place all the way until July
or August it is currently March 17th do
you really think the American people are
going to shelter in place for four
months okay that that is something is
just not going to happen
realistically speaking it's not going to
happen here's President Trump suggesting
the outbreak could last until July or
August then dr. Anthony foul she said
well the restrictions aren't gonna last
until July are out or August but the
outbreak could it seems to me that if we
do a really good job will not only hold
the death down to a level that is much
lower than the other way had we not done
a good job but people are talking about
July August something like that so it
could be right in that period of time
where it I say wash it washes through
other people don't like that term but
would washes Karev okay so that that of
course is a fairly accurate take some
people are even suggesting that by early
May as the summer kicks in we may see an
alleviation of the virus itself
president Trump finally acknowledging
the economy could be headed into
recession look the fact is that the
early handling of this by the Trump
administration was not good as I've said
for about a week Trump
wised up
late last week and he has now been
taking a very serious tack on all this
which is correct here's Trump yesterday
announcing the economy could be headed
into recession stock market took another
hit today is the US economy heading into
a recession well it may be when I think
in terms of recession we're thinking in
terms of the virus once we stop I think
there's a tremendous pent up demand both
in terms of the stock market in terms of
the economy and once this goes away once
it goes through and we're done with it I
think you're gonna see a tremendous a
tremendous surge okay President Trump
also suggested that the best thing for
the stock market is to get through the
crisis which of course is true and does
speak to what exactly are the financial
measures that are being taken this is
why the suggestion that the Fed lowering
its rate to zero was going to jog the
economy as idiotic until this whole
thing is actually solved there isn't
gonna be no jog to the economy right now
it's just a matter of get through it get
through it until either a vaccine is
found or until the summer kills off this
wuhan virus here as ears President Trump
continued to fall today the stock market
is we have to get through this crisis
that's what I can do that's the best
thing we can do that's what I think
about once once this virus has gone I
think you're gonna have a stock market
like nobody's ever seen before and and
of course I think there's truth to that
as well I mean the fact is that when we
do come out of this this will have been
a very good time to buy stock but not a
lot of people have tons of disposable
income considering that their businesses
are being shot down President Trump did
say that we now recommend that nobody
gather in groups of 10 so so much for a
or how it for Europe for your holiday
party gang and if you have a family of
12 then I guess two of them are out on
the doorstep there's President Trump my
administration is recommending that all
Americans including the young and
healthy work to engage in schooling from
home when possible avoid gathering in
groups of more than 10 people avoid
discretionary travel and avoid eating
and drinking at bars restaurants and
public food courts if everyone makes
this change or these critical changes
and sacrifices now we will rally
together as one nation and we will
defeat the virus and we're going to have
a big celebration all together
okay and
all of that is true all that we need is
one of three things to happen we need a
massive increase in the number of ICU
beds and ventilators we need this Lu Han
virus vaccine right now or we need the
summer to kill off the flu
now again even if the summer kills off
the flute we are still going to need
that increase in ICU beds we're still
going to need that increase in in
vaccine the reason being that there
could be a second wave of this what
people don't realize about the Spanish
flu they're actually three waves of the
Spanish flu wave number two was the one
that killed the most people President
Trump in in another piece of good news
he suggests that a vaccine candidate for
phase one has begun in actuality there
are actually several candidates for a
Phase one vaccine there's one here I
believe there's one in Germany I believe
there's one in Israel here is President
Trump I'm also pleased to report today
that a vaccine candidate has begun the
Phase one clinical trial this is one of
the fastest vaccine development launches
in history not even close we're also
racing to develop antiviral therapies
and other treatments that we've had some
promising results early results but
promising to reduce the severity and the
duration of the sender of the symptoms
and I have to say that our government is
prepared to do whatever it takes
whatever it takes we're doing the acting
DHS secretary added that a domestic
travel shutdown is on the table that of
course makes perfect sense considering
that nobody's flying anyway I mean the
airlines have taken a massive hit here's
the acting DHS secretary announcing that
we may shut down the airlines as you
heard the president say it's certainly
something that we continue to look at
certainly in the task force there are no
immediate plans for any domestic travel
restrictions but as I often say we like
to keep all options on the table and
again as the virus continues to evolve
and our medical strategy continues to
evolve then that's certainly something
that we'll take a look at deborah birx
who's heading up the president's
coronavirus response
she also says we're looking at the best
responses from everywhere look the
entire federal government is on this
thing so are all the state governments
again the big question is going to be
what's the end date here what's the end
date because the fact is that we're
already seeing this in countries around
the world people are already coming out
of isolation especially free countries
we're not going to have people with
machine guns in the streets telling
people to get back in their homes thank
god it's a good thing that means that
the number of people who are going to
stay in place especially if the numbers
don't dramatically skyrocket and freak
everybody out that eventually people are
going to go back
streets here's Deborah Burke saying
we're looking at good responses from
everywhere I think we're looking at all
the experience that has been gained
around the world we spend every day
reviewing what has happened in China
South Korea Italy Iran and across the
world to really see how people have
responded there's a China model there's
a South Korea model we're taking the
best of each of those models and working
on seeing how we adapt them yeah well so
all of that is true it's funny so then
the media been playing this thing very
oddly in some areas for example they've
been saying that the federal response
was following the state response yes
because states are built for this I mean
this is what federalism is built on
localism the abilities of States to
declare national emergencies is or state
emergencies is far greater than the
capacity of the federal government to
declare such emergencies of course this
thing should have started at the local
and state level in terms of the
initiation of lockdowns like this for
all of that the president has now put
out a document called 15 days to slow
the spread now this does not mean that
all these restrictions are gonna end
after 15 days that is very unlikely okay
the the high likelihood at this point is
that this thing is going to continue at
least another month if I had to put my
thumb on it I would think that it would
be at least another four to six weeks
minimum okay but with that said the
president has said there are 15 days to
slow the spread because the very least
you have to take one running punch at
coronavirus by preventing the rapid
spread to give the government time to
catch up so here are the here are the
the guidelines they say listen to and
follow the directions of your state and
local authorities if you feel sick stay
home do not go to work contact your
medical provider if your children are
sick keep them at home do not send them
to school contact your medical provider
if someone in your household is tested
positive for the corona virus keep the
entire household at home do not go to
work do not go to school contact your
medical provider if you're an older
person stay home and away from other
people if you're a person with a serious
underlying health condition that can put
you at increased risk for example a
condition that impairs lung or heart
function or weakens your immune system
stay home and away from other people
even if you are young or otherwise
healthy says the White House you're at
risk your activities can increase the
risk for others it's critical using your
part to slow the spread of the corona
virus and this of course has led to a
fair bit of controversy between sort of
young people and older people there's an
interesting article in The Wall Street
Journal today about how some young
people are like I'm
want to live my life man and if the
oldies get it than the old okay that is
a fairly a moral point of view you
staying home for a couple of listenig
the economy's gonna take the hit anyway
you staying home for a couple of weeks
from the bar and killing your social
life for a couple of weeks to save
grandma actually that's something you
sort of odd to Grandma hey do your part
to slow the spread of the coronavirus
says the White House work or engage in
schooling from home whenever possible if
you work in a critical infrastructure
industry is defined by the DHS such as
health care services in pharmaceutical
and food supply have a special
responsibility to maintain your normal
work schedule avoid social gatherings
and groups of more than 10 people avoid
eating or drinking at bars at
restaurants and food courts use
drive-thru pickup or delivery options
avoid discretionary travel shopping
trips and social visits do not visit
nursing homes or retirement or long-term
care facilities and of course wash your
hands avoid touching your face sneezing
or coughing to a tissue or the inside of
your elbow disinfect frequently used
items and services as much as possible
they also say that older people are
particularly at risk all states should
follow federal guidance and halt social
visits to nursing homes and retirement
and long-term care facilities and they
recommend that all states shut down bars
restaurants food courts gyms and other
indoor and outdoor venues where groups
of people congregate so this thing is is
going to be rough obviously and
president Trump has gotten serious about
it the White House has gotten serious
about it I keep repeating it but the
reality is we are not gonna know how
successful any of this stuff was until
we get to the summer we're just not
going to know that the statistics by the
way the coronavirus map continues to to
add numbers to it we had about 18 deaths
in the United States from coronavirus
that doesn't sound like a lot
considering that we are in a country of
330 million people or so but the the
numbers are climbing as I said before
that's a good thing okay the fact that
the the numbers are climbing means that
there's more tests that are now
available and there are drive-through
tests that are being made available with
all of that said Governor Andrew Cuomo
is basically the tip of the spear in
declaring this an emergency he's been
asking for literally tens of thousands
of ICU beds from the federal government
which is something the federal
government mean takes time to generate
that sort of stuff Cuomo has a piece in
The New York Times today says dear mr.
president the corona virus pandemic is
now upon us data from other countries
shows clearly where we are headed
every country affected by this crisis
has handled it on a national basis the
United States is not okay first of all
that is
not true okay Italy did not hand it on
national basis they they've shut down
northern Italy then they finally shut
down the entire country they lagged yeah
we are actually not lagging nearly as
bad as Italy did were several days ahead
of Italy in terms of our response and
Cuomo says state and local governments
alone simply do not have the capacity or
resources to do what is necessary and we
don't want a patchwork quilt of policies
okay but again the federal government
can declare the policies but it's very
difficult to actually effectuate those
policies without the state and
localities actually making that happen
and and Cuomo says there is now only one
question your team must answer for you
can we slow the spread of the disease to
a rate that our state healthcare systems
can handle the answer increasingly looks
like no that doesn't mean that we should
not try there are fewer options
available at this late date the federal
government should move to implement them
and swiftly he say that we need more
tests obviously and there were screw-ups
by the CDC throughout this entire
process Joe Biden falsely claimed that
the president rejected w-h-o test that's
not true the CDC just screwed this thing
up they said they had the test then they
didn't actually have the test in
somebody somebody's had at the CDC needs
to roll for that when all of this is
done also Cuomo suggests that we have to
have closing of schools and businesses
and those have federal implications and
we need to have consistency in those
shutdowns he says some things about the
ability of businesses to simply cross
state lines that that I think is a
little bit exaggerated with that said
the federal government is now engaging
in commercial buying of paper which is
actually a very good thing they need to
do that because that is basically
ensuring that those short-term loans
that many small businesses are reliant
upon don't get called in immediately and
then Cuomo's big ask is that the federal
government actually mobilize the the
army in order to build new facilities
Cuomo says you must anticipate without
certain action the imminent failure of
hospital systems is all but certain
according to one projection as many as
214 million people in our country could
be infected over the course of the
epidemic of those as many 20 as 21
million people could require
hospitalization which would crush the
nation's medical system New York State
has just 53,000 470 hospital beds only
3,100 of which are intensive care beds
which of course is not even close to the
number that we need our country as a
whole has fewer than 1 million staffed
hospital beds fewer proportionately than
China South Korea or Italy okay but
we're also a little more spread out than
South Korea or Italy for example
it is also true that we are obtaining
the disease at least by best available
statistics at a lower rate than some of
those other countries but do we need to
build more hospitals absolutely do we
need more beds created absolutely Cuomo
is calling on Trump to free up the Army
Corps of Engineers to leverage its
expertise equipment and power people
proud power to retrofit and equip
existing facilities to serve as
temporary medical centers that is
probably a good idea okay but there's
probably a good idea so all of those
resources are going to be brought to
bear okay in just a second we're gonna
get to more on this we'll bring you the
latest from the from the corona virus
counts which are escalating they've not
been escalating in China and they've not
been escalating in South Korea which is
really interesting because again life
seems to be opening up there again which
again is a very good sign I mean that
means that the economy will recover once
this stuff is over we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about a
certain reality and that is that if you
want to keep yourself and your family
safe one thing that would be very useful
at a time like this is of course owning
a firearm owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility building a rifle is no
different started in garage by Marine
veteran more than two decades ago Bravo
company manufacturing builds a
professional-grade product which is
built to combat standards that's because
BCM believes the same level of
protection should be provided to every
American regardless if they're a private
citizen or a professional the people at
BCM assume that when a rifle leads their
shop it will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas so every components of a BCM
rifle is hand assembled and tested to a
life-saving standard the people at BCM
believe it's their moral responsibility
as Americans to provide tools that will
not fail when it's not just a paper
target and whenever there is a difficult
situation you always worry about crime
rates rising protecting yourself
protecting your family it's an
imperative go check out my friends at
Bravo company manufacturing head on over
to Bravo Company MFG comm you can
discover more about their product
special offers and upcoming news that is
Bravo Company MFG comm you should check
out their awesome videos to meet the
great people who make their products at
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA
again that's youtube.com slash a Bravo
Company USA okay so here are the latest
counts with regard to the with regard to
the coronavirus so about 190,000 total
confirmed cases across a planet earth
right now they're about 81 thousand in
China that's been stagnant for quite a
while and China's reopening live which
again I keep saying this that's actually
really good news I mean that does
suggest that once this thing is shut
down to a certain extent that it sort of
dies out and is less transmissible so
that that's a good thing
Italy is continuing to see an escalation
they've got 28,000 total cases in Italy
with 21 158 deaths in Italy but it seems
that even in Italy this thing may be
leveling off just a little bit Iran is
reporting statistics that are completely
false they say they have 16,000 cases in
Iran those that that's probably off by
maybe even an order of magnitude Spain
is starting to see an escalation the
United States has about 5000 diagnosed
cases again you should expect that to
spike we only have 85 deaths so far and
most of those are still in the nursing
homes in Washington State about 40 of
those from a nursing home in Washington
State so go so that those are the
current statistics that we are seeing in
just a second we're gonna get to the
idiotic controversy of the day we're
giving you all the information but
there's an idiotic controversy of the
day the idiotic controversy of the day
is that the President of the United
States labeled this the Chinese but the
Chinese virus which of course is the end
of the world we'll get to why this is
utterly uncontroversial naturally it's a
good thing that Trump is saying this
we'll get to that in a second first gang
gotta tell you daily where our
membership is the only way you should be
viewing our content you're missing all
the best features right now using promo
code Shapiro you get 10% off any member
plan you choose become part of our
community what makes memberships so
great well members get our articles had
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library the full
three hours of the Ben Shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and more plus our new all-access
cheer it gets you into exclusive live
online Q&A discussions with me Andrew
Clavin Matt Walsh Michael moles plus
daily we're writers and special guests
don't forget you also get the greatest
of all beverage vessels right here
before you the leftist tears tumblr you
get all that plus 10% off when you use
promo code Shapiro I should also mention
that thanks to corona virus and the
shutdown we've been trying to ensure
that we can all hang out together all of
our members last night for example he
got together and we all talked to movies
it just me and Jeremy boring and we hung
out with in a social distancing area and
elbow bumped and then talked about
movies and religion for an hour I
thought there's a lot of fun it creates
a sense of community it makes you feel
not quite as alone in this time win I
think a lot of people are feeling
isolated so come join our community it
really is a lot of fun stop depriving
yourself
come join fun will hang out together
through all this you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative pod
and radio show in the United States
[Music]
so the federal government has now
proposed an 850 billion dollar emergency
fiscal package that is a good idea
because if it is targeted again at
commercial paper its targeted at shoring
up those small businesses that don't
want to have their loans called in on
them and that is a that is a useful
thing it's not going to reactivate
economic activity of course it would be
idiotic to suggest economic activity is
reactivated as coronavirus continues to
plague the globe meanwhile everybody is
apparently a about about labeling
the coronavirus wuhan flu or the Chinese
virus president in trumpet last night
tweeted about the Chinese virus and he
tweeted this the United States will be
powerfully supporting those industries
like Airlines and others that are
particularly affected by the Chinese
virus will be stronger than ever before
and everybody was like that's so racist
that so it is not racist stop with this
stupid crap it originated in China it is
the fault of the Chinese government that
it exited China's borders for a month
trying to sat on this thing and tried to
jail people who talked openly about it
so don't give me this garbage that
somehow it's racist against random
Chinese people to point out that the
virus originated in China not only is it
not racist it's a good thing that the
president continues to call it the
Chinese virus why because Chinese
diplomats are now pushing conspiracy
theories trying to blame this on the
United States literally they are trying
to do this okay a little bit earlier
last week a prominent Chinese diplomat
tweeted a conspiracy theory that the
corona virus did not originate in Wuhan
but the United States instead Licio and
Jiao a deputy director-general the
information department of China's
foreign ministry tweeted this article is
very much important to each and every
one of us please read and retweeted
covet 19 further evidence that the virus
originated in the United States and
China is trying to throw off its
responsibility for this whole thing and
honestly in the aftermath of this if we
were not a parent before you know I've
said many times over the course of years
I am NOT certain that the United States
Nixon administration's decision to open
China was actually a good idea we may
have been better off simply continuing
to economically boycott China and then
let the communist regime collapse in on
itself the same way that we did with the
USSR okay right now the rest of the
world needs to seriously consider
whether we should be doing business with
China on an ongoing basis this is just
further proof forget all of their human
rights violations for the moment forget
the fact that they keep a billion Weger
in abject servitude and slavery and jail
conditions just because they're Muslim
forget the fact
that China has repressed a billion
people in a horrific system of communist
oppression that has resulted in the
deaths of literally hundreds of millions
of unborn babies
I mean really like forced abortion from
from the 1970s through 2015 was
responsible for if not 10 if not
hundreds of millions babies at least
tens of millions of babies and the
forced sterilization millions of women
is an evil evil regime and the evil of
the regime was shown for everybody to
see when this virus was basically
unleashed upon an unsuspecting world
because the Chinese government wanted to
uphold its credibility with its own
citizenry we're all gonna have to decide
and I mean corporations I mean
governments whether we want to continue
to do business with an aggressive state
that cares so little about the rest of
the world they are willing to silence
their own citizens even it means the
rest of the world has to suffer death
and privation and the entire world
economy shudders to a halt okay so yes
this should be labeled to Chinese virus
it is a Chinese virus to pretend that it
is not that is a that is a referendum on
the regime it's not a referendum on the
people of China who are great it is not
a referendum on Chinese people abroad
who are wonderful it is a referendum on
the Chinese government which is a bag of
garbage and has been a bag of garbage
for decades by the way in breaking news
my Pence is now asking construction
companies to donate an additional
industrial masks to the medical
community and forgo additional orders of
masks at this time which makes sense
construction isn't exactly ongoing CNN
is reporting 97 people have died and at
least 5,000 confirmed cases of the
corona virus according to the CDC again
those numbers are going to jump the
numbers jumping shouldn't scare you it
should be evidence that we're starting
to finally get this thing under control
via testing you're gonna see those
numbers skyrocket in future days and
then we look for it to level off okay
time for a quick thing that I like and
then a couple of quick things that I
hate so things that I like today so if
you're looking for something creepy but
not too creepy to read go check out the
complete tales and poems of Edgar Allan
Poe perhaps the greatest American writer
whose command of language is absolutely
beautiful and if you want to read
something that's if you're into you know
watching the movie Contagion and
freaking yourself out the best pandemic
story of course is the mask of the Red
Death by Edgar Allan Poe so if you're in
a very dark mood read that but otherwise
Edgar Allen Poe is just a master at what
he does and and you know his and his
writing is beautiful so go check out
some Edgar Allan Poe like now's a good
time to catch up on your classics
reading so if you don't remember all
that stuff you were supposed to read in
high school now's a good time to catch
up on all of that
maybe we'll dedicate one of these these
sort of special daily wire episodes that
we've been doing just for our listeners
and our members but maybe we'll dedicate
one of those to book choices and
discussing solid book choices over the
course of the next several weeks when we
are all home and those of us who do not
have kids may have some extra time on
our hands if you have kids basically are
just trying to keep yourself from not
going insane at this point okay time for
a quick thing that I hate Bill DeBlasio
the mayor of New York's an idiot like a
full on stop
full stop okay by the way so is
mayor Garcetti of LA mayor Garcetti of
LA I've mentioned this a couple of weeks
ago so some of us took coronavirus
pretty seriously a few weeks ago like I
told my wife several weeks ago to go out
shopping because I thought this thing
might get bad but with all of that said
Eric Garcetti even at the time mayor of
Los Angeles
he left the LA he let the LA Marathon go
on no problem 20,000 people out sweating
and coughing on each other just a genius
move by Eric Garcetti who also has
allowed tens of thousands of homeless
people to clog up the streets of Los
Angeles providing a public health risk
that has been ongoing in the city for a
long time okay bill de blasio is of the
same order except more he's just a
full-scale idiot I mean a full
so yesterday for example look at the
difference between I mean just
unbelievable de Blasio says we have to
be on war footing to tackle coronavirus
okay fair enough here's bill de blasio
explaining that to Mika Brzezinski over
at MSNBC we need a national solution
this should be a reality where the
United States has put on a war footing
where the federal government mobilizes
all the resources necessary we're going
to need the United States military to
come in with their substantial
logistical and medical capacity we're
going to need the supply chain
nationalized in some form right now how
about the fact that the United States is
the best of my knowledge the United
States military right now is still
engaged in building those border walls
take them off that and put them on
coronavirus for God's sakes it okay
first of all these are not mutually
exclusive second of all I do not think
that mass numbers of the American
military are building the border wall
right now the sort of politicization is
completely idiotic but perfectly
predictable considering politics in this
country never stops even in the middle
of pandemic okay that same idiot
de Blasio was filmed going into a YMCA
to workout despite the fact that I
believe there is a current gym shut down
in New York City you're not supposed to
go to the gym because it is indeed a
germ Factory and unfortunately
coronavirus lives on metal for days on
end which is why you know ask people
around the office I advised them a
couple of like a week ago and I myself
did this to go out and get some gym
equipment at home have it delivered via
Amazon which by the way it
thank God France and you although you
morons who are ripping on Amazon like
five minutes ago all you idiots who are
like Amazon's an evil rapacious company
guess who's keeping the country going
right now Hey Amazon is about to hire a
hundred thousand people because of all
of the demand for people ordering online
yes a private company that has made your
life better still doing great work
that's the same company Bill DeBlasio
and a oco-2 ranking over the coals five
minutes ago anyway Bill DeBlasio he says
he's gonna he said he was asked why he
went to the gym to stay healthy and a
bunch of people in New York are like are
you a he just told everybody else
they can't go to the gym and here you
are going to the gym here's Bill
DeBlasio defending himself going to the
gym he's not murdering groundhogs I did
not for a moment think there was
anything problematic because I knew the
dynamics again I have to stay healthy so
I can make the decisions for the people
the city just unbelievable he needs to
stay healthy to make decisions for the
people of the city by going to a gym
that he's telling everybody else not to
go to what an absolute genius speaking
of politicization again the politics of
this country do not stop for five
seconds james Clyburn who is the the
representative in south carolina who
endorsed joe biden and pretty much put
him over the top there put him on the
path to the nomination yesterday he was
on Axios on HBO comparing President
Trump in the Republicans to the Nazis
because this crap just doesn't stop it
just doesn't stop doing this State of
the Union address Trump told thirty-one
lies for the half of those lives the
Republican side that I was standing up
in cheering they knew that was not true
but they cheered him on I really believe
that the people of Germany knew it off
was lying but it Jade alone and before
they knew it they no longer had a
chancellor but a dictator anything
that's happened before can have them
again
so what we're now seriously it's
hilarious the same people who are saying
that Donald Trump is Hitler and Mike
Pence is gurbles or something these same
people are suggesting the Donald Trump
needs to fully take over the entire
United States economy and now shutting
down the entire country like I'm gonna
have to pick one like this this idea
that that the republican party is
Hitlerian is so hilariously ridiculous
but politics again does not stop no
matter the situation can't stop won't
stop even even Andrew Cuomo who is going
at it with with President Trump over all
of this and Trump going right back and
Andrew Cuomo over all this I mean this
would be the time for for cooperation
and coordination and if Cuomo asked for
something and Trump says we don't have
the federal resources right now which is
sort of what happened on a phone call
yesterday a bunch of Governors were on
the phone with Trump and they're like
can you get us ventilators intern was
like you should first try and get the
convent's let we'll try to help but we
don't really have that great access
either I mean it's not like we have a
big stock pile of ventilators over here
we're ready to hand you so you should be
trying to get it yourself
this was promoted by the media without
Trump saying that we'll try to help you
because people still have an agenda even
in times of global pandemic all of this
crap has to stop put it aside for the
moment I think that Americans are I just
think that our politicians are not
because when you're a professional
politician you're a hammer in search of
a nail and that just never stops
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of constant
otherwise we'll be back here tomorrow
don't worry we're getting through this
together it's gonna be fine really it
will emit I really believe that word
that this thing will die out by summer I
think that I've said before I think that
we're gonna get on track and look at
China I'm encouraged I look at South
Korea I'm encouraged I look at Hong Kong
I'm encouraged I think that we're gonna
get this thing on track it's just gonna
require some sacrifice by all of us but
we can stick through it together
it's temporary it is not permanent so
just keep that in mind and hang out with
us we'll just hang out together
it'll be fine I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2025 major US cities shutdown to
stop the spread of the wolf flu but as
we rush to save our lives as coronavirus
killing our Constitution we will examine
the surprising civics lessons of this
pandemic then former future Democrat
governor of Florida and potential vice
presidential candidate Andrew Gilliam is
found vomiting in a hotel room with a
naked male prostitute and a bunch of
meth we will analyze as it were how the
press lets him off the hook all that
more check it out on the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]